[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis très heureux d'avoir pu signer
avec monsieur alain schultz directeur
général délégué à la science du cnrs ce
partenariat qui va compléter la
stratégie de l'opéra et déco territoire
de l'opéra et qui rentre dans la logique
de développement durable et la rse que
le cnrs le même porte fortement auprès
de ces chercheurs et ses laboratoires
l'idée générale dans cet aménagement du
territoire c'est de développer un
territoire développement durable de
faire attention effectivement à tous les
enjeux d'énergie et sur le sud plateau
que le projet porte et qui accueille la
plupart des du pôle académique a été
retenu l'idée d'avoir depuis longtemps
un réseau des changes de chaud et de
froid qui permettent d'optimiser la
consommation et qui s'appuie sur des
ressources énergétiques renouvelables
alors commencer par la géothermie
puisque c'est le leclerc du système mais
aussi du soleil en électricité
le réseau mais aussi c'est ce
partenariat d'aujourd'hui qui permet de
travailler ce qu'on appelle l'énergie
fatale récupérer la chaleur fatale du
grand calculateur que le cnrs à
développer sur le territoire et qualité
mistral ici un nom qui s'appelle idriss
l'iddri 7
un grand calculateur qui est utilisé
pour faire des calculs scientifiques
dans tous les domaines c'est même le
plus puissant en france actuellement et
en particulier il a une dimension sur le
calcul de l'intelligence artificielle et
comme calculateur bien qu'il ait été
conçu pour consommer le moins d'énergie
possible
il chauffe et donc il ya de la chaleur
qui sort des systèmes de refroidissement
et le but de cette convention c'est de
faire en sorte que cette chaleur puisse
être récupérée pour chauffer ou faire de
la climatisation ça dépend de la saison
sur les bâtiments qui sont autour
juste pour donner un ordre de grandeur
c'est ça représente à peu près
l'énergie consommée par mille logements
dans une année très calculateur est très
jeune il a été inauguré il ya à peine un
an et on a réussi à faire un âne en une
convention qui va permettre de
réutiliser cette énergie tout ça ça se
place dans une stratégie de réflexion
sur la pratique du métier de chercheur
et faire en sorte que tout en gardant
notre excellence scientifique on arrive
à diminuer notablement notre empreinte
environnementale et notre empreinte
carbone globale de l'ensemble du plateau
[Musique]